World Elites descending on Davos to
strategize how to fix all the world's
problems President Biden's climates are
former Secretary of State John Kerry
boasting about a plan to save our planet
it's pretty extraordinary
that we select group of human beings
because of whatever touched us at some
point in our lives are able to sit in a
room and come together
and actually talk about saving the
planet I mean it's so almost
extraterrestrial to think about quote
saving the planet if you said that to
most people most people they think
you're just a crazy tree-hugging Lefty
liberal you know do-good or whatever
and former vice president Al Gore
painting a rather dismal picture of what
pollution is doing to Mother Earth
that's what's boiling the oceans
creating these atmospheric rivers and
the rain bombs and sucking the moisture
out of the land and creating the
droughts and melting the ice and raising
the sea level and causing these waves of
climate refugees predicted to reach 1
billion in this Century we have to act
the vice president has been moved by
this issue for a long time Dana as you
as you think about this is this the
right form for these or good do good
ideas come out of this form are there
are actionable ideas that come out of or
is it just a bunch of rich people I know
I know that 1040 private planes showed
up for this meeting I don't know if they
attended Al Gore's lecture there as to
what John Kerry said
he said isn't it amazing that we
something that touched that was taught
we were touched we are the special ones
we are the ones here who are going we
get to sit in a room and talk about
saving the planet what about doing to
save the planet and what about the
people who are not touched like John
Kerry who might live in Nairobi in the
Congo maybe maybe there maybe uh in
places in Africa for example where
they've been denied the ability to
develop resources so that they could
have their own energy and electricity
and become more independent which could
lead to more Innovation so that we could
get to something like Fusion sooner and
we could all do something good for the
planet on that point
um and then here's the thing also they
want to focus on climate change but they
don't talk about China
the China energy Investment Group that
is the main entity that is expanding use
of coal there why wouldn't they talk
about it there well guess what I found
out
they're a sponsor of course of Davos of
course
judge you sound like you're ready
China is everywhere China's in the
universities China's in the in the uh uh
in in the colleges I mean it's in the
government uh we shouldn't be surprised
it's in sports it's in movies uh here's
what this we have a select group of
human beings imagine we're talking about
the planet the rest of the people
they're just roops they don't know
anything there is such a condescending
kind of arrogant they pontificate about
themselves and the truth is they're
spending our tax dollars we're working
and they're spending our money we've
already spent a trillion dollars for
renewable energy and it's the richest
countries that have the lowest carbon
emissions other than you know China
which is not the richest yet but the
money that that that's being spent
because they talk about money money
money is money that the United States is
giving to other governments so they they
tax us call us rooms in and then they
run around in their private planes you
know Greg in The Green Room you told me
what do you think about the uh about
this the the speech by by vice president
Gore well I agree with you completely
was an absolute total embarrassment and
I'm glad you said that
you can look back in the show and you'll
find it there why is it so you look at
like Al Gore you look at John Kerry why
are the people that are so consumed by
the health of the planet look so
unhealthy why do they look so sick I
mean they're talking about sucking the
moisture out of the earth that guy looks
like he needs watering right he's got
the complexion of a dilapidated
Tumbleweed and I mean they're all like
they're all like
Driftwood they all come together for one
year and Pat each other on their
splintered backs I'll tell you what you
know what
I forgot what I was gonna say
the the
stelter's there when all else fails
stelter is there talking about
disinformation isn't that amazing what's
he gonna talk about next how to get
washboard abs
seriously I'm not invited to these
things because I have Solutions and if
you go there with solutions they can't
have their fun anymore so the climate
change thing is great because every year
that's always going to be the problem
always the problem you can still have
your Davos party you can still fly in
because it'll never be solved first time
interesting for Davos the oil company
CEOs or or in demand at these at this
this conference for the first time in a
long time is that right yeah yeah I'm
just glad Greg is now talking about
people's physical appearances it's it's
nice to have someone else pull their
weight around here Bush beat these two
guys Carrie and Gore and now they've
Fallen apart
um they're losers and they know it so
now they have to be someone else's
savior if you're Al Gore and you have to
create a term called a rain bomb to
convince me that I need to give up more
of my money to save the world that's not
doing it boiling the oceans talk about
it normally and then maybe I'll be more
open-minded and a little advice for John
on carrot you don't say you're saving
the world you say you saved the world
it's very arrogant to say that you're
saving it
save it and then brag
that's what I did hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else